matpat my son we need to have a talk
your father and i are very concerned
about this whole
youtube thing when are you planning to
stop making little online vlog videos
and get out there and get a real job
hey look at me hey
i really look like a guy with a plan
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory a
show that goes into each episode with no
plan we just do things and hope that
each step in our insanely detailed
takeover of youtube falls precisely into
place speaking of taking over youtube
today
is a huge day in that plan today we are
launching
the first new theory channel in over
six years oh my god has it really been
that long six years
introducing food theory yep we're
theorizing about food with five new
theory episodes for you to watch
right now after you finish this one and
i know that theorizing about food may
sound weird at first but the same deep
research
over analysis science and speculation
that we put to use on superheroes
cartoons and disney over here
absolutely apply to the very real world
topics of cooking
shopping restaurant psychology lies that
the food industry is telling us
everything for instance
did you know that coffee is probably the
thing responsible for the creation of
modern physics or that if you value the
money in your wallet you should never
order an arby's medium fry or that the
kool-aid man is an official marvel hero
with
deep ties into the x-men or or that
movie theater popcorn is like the most
valuable food in the world we're also
doing things like coming to the
definitive answer about some of the food
world's biggest debates like whether
a hot dog is a sandwich or not spoiler
alert
pizza and chicken wings might qualify
too anyway
this is a channel that is literally
built on the principle
of brain food so if you like what we do
here i guarantee that you'll enjoy
food theory as well so please head on
over to that channel right now and hit
subscribe it is without exaggeration
the single best way that you can help
this channel out right now
and let's be honest it's not like
youtube is gonna show you new videos on
your feet anyway
so really there's no reason not to just
helps people take this channel more
seriously anyway
thank you thank you for considering
watching thank you for your support over
there thank you most of all for your
subscription
in a really sucky year working on this
new channel has been a really
great change of pace for all us on
theorist team but what would be
really really great is seeing that you
guys are out there excited about it
supporting it so please help in any way
that you can
link to that channel as well as its
first couple of episodes are in the top
lines of the description
alright alright enough shilling let's
talk batman we're more accurately
the joker under normal world
circumstances this is the time of year
that i get most excited about movies
it's when all the studios pull out their
biggest franchises and just create a
summer blockbuster season full of
weekend after weekend of killer films
sure they might not always be great
um suicide squad dark phoenix but they
are always fun to go and see and
certainly fun to talk about but the lack
of new summer movies this year has
gotten me to try and recreate that
excitement at home by re-watching some
of my all-time favorite superhero films
starting of course with the christopher
nolan batman films just so i had an
excuse to watch dark knight again
it is so great i don't tend to re-watch
movies
a whole lot but dark knight is one that
i just always gravitate back to
i know that we have so many amazing
superhero films these days but man this
one still holds up with so many iconic
scenes the opening heist
the pencil magic trick the hospital
explosion but this time one scene in
particular really caught my attention
the money pyramid
i never really stopped to think about it
but that is a huge
huge pile of cash that the joker has as
we learn about the movie it's some
combination of his various heist
earnings as well as half the collective
income of the gotham mafia and then the
joker just you know goes and sets it all
on fire
and all of it just to prove a point so
what i want to figure out today is
just how expensive that point really was
how much money is in that gigantic stack
of cash of his how much work would it
take to set up
and most importantly of all what does it
tell us about the true nature of this
character
because tell you what despite the joker
appearing like this chaotic force
the money pyramid scene proves that he's
anything but
so in order to calculate how much money
the joker's sitting on top of we have to
get a sense of the pyramid's general
dimensions
from some of the wide shots at the
beginning of the scene we see that the
pyramid is composed of 10
separate tiers each tier roughly the
same height if you zoom in on the
highest resolution and count you'll see
that the height of each tier
is about 30 straps of cash hi now i'm
assuming that this whole pile is made of
hundred dollar bills
for several reasons during the initial
robbery i saw that they were only
stealing ten thousand dollar straps
of cash also when doing the research i
came across the movie props
of this particular scene which are all
hundred dollar bills
so knowing that ten thousand dollars is
one hundred one hundred dollar bills we
take the thickness of one bill
0.0043 inches or 0.01 centimeters and
then multiply by 100 to get the height
of a single stack that gives us
0.43 inches or a little over one
centimeter 30 of those stacked on top of
each other is going to get us
just under 13 inches or around 33
centimeters
so each tier is slightly over a foot
high meaning that the whole
pyramid of 10 tiers is 10 feet 9 inches
or about 3.3 meters high we can also gut
check this number by seeing the joker
standing at both the top and bottom of
the pile heath ledger the actor who
played the joker was just over six foot
tall meaning that the tower should be
roughly twice his height a little bit
less and yeah that looks about right
for reference that makes joker's money
pile approximately the same height as
stonehenge
except much cooler because it's
literally comprised of money as opposed
to
rocks that aliens decided to throw
together for no apparent reason so
that's the height but what about the
width well
width in this case is also pretty easy
all we have to do again is count the
straps of cash
once we do that knowing that a typical
hundred dollar bill is six inches long
or 15 centimeters long we can calculate
the width of each tier going up which
starts at about 20 feet or six meters at
its base and step by step gets smaller
and smaller
18 feet 16 feet 14 feet 12 11 10
9 8 and finally seven all of which i've
marked on screen for you and with those
dimensions out of the way we can finally
start to figure out how much
cash is actually in this thing let's
start with the bottom shall we since the
process is the same
all the way up the pyramid based on our
counting as well as the dimensions of a
hundred dollar bill the bottom tier is
made of 39 stacks of cash long and 92
stacks of cash wide this
means that there are 107
640 stacks of cash on this bottom tier
alone
all of which are ten thousand dollars a
piece that is
one billion dollars 1 billion
76 million 400 000 to be exact and that
is only for the first
level of the pyramid joker is a
billionaire and we've barely gotten off
the ground in a literal and figurative
sense now
this number seemed way too big for me so
i tried it a different way
we know that the bottom level is roughly
20 foot by 20 foot and we know
the height of that bottom level so i
calculated the volume
of that which ended up being about 748
800 cubic inches and divided by the
volume of a single hundred dollar bill
which is about point zero six eight nine
cubic inches to see how many bills would
be needed to fill
that bottom tier's volume the results
nearly 11
million hundred dollar bills meaning
that again the total amount of cash is
roughly around 1.1 billion
dollars after doing that same process
nine more times for the rest of the
pyramid i concluded the final result to
be
468 000 straps of cash
creating the eye-watering grand total of
4 billion 688 million dollars
two-bit whack job wears a cheap purple
suit and makeup
the suit it wasn't cheap you ought to
know you bought it
that puts the joker no joke into the top
hundred richest
people in the u.s right now alongside
oprah winfrey that's right next time
you're hanging out with your comics
buddies quiz em on what the joker has in
common with
oprah bet they're not gonna guess that
one now could there be some wooden
structure underneath like how they
display fruit in a grocery store
sure maybe but i'm not convinced that
there is look at when the joker slides
down the pyramid there are stacks of
cash
deep within this structure plus consider
the weight of all this money
that amount of cash would weigh 51 tons
a hundred and two thousand pounds of
pure
money no street goons are gonna be able
to run down to the local home depot and
architect together something to hold
that amount of weight so quickly
i think it's gotta be pure cash but as
you can imagine
i was still skeptical as i have no doubt
you are too that is an insane
amount of money and i've learned from
doing these episodes for nearly 10 years
that sometimes my math yields numbers
that if i don't gut check them get me
burned in the comments except here's the
thing
the reality of this situation holds firm
let's start by covering how he acquired
the billions of dollars in the first
place since the joker is stealing from
the gotham mafia and various crime
organizations the number
isn't as far-fetched as it might seem in
the mafia in the usa brought in 50 to 90
billion dollars per year and in italy in
2008 the family there
was earning an estimated 250 million
euros
per day via their various businesses man
that was a sentence with a lot of air
quotes anyway gotham is a major city in
the u.s so it's not unbelievable that
the ruling crime families would have
billions spread out across the city the
thing that seals the deal though
is their accountant lao when the joker
crashes in on the major gotham gangsters
we learn that lau
their accountant has moved all of their
money together to avoid the cash getting
seized by harvey dent
this means that billions of dollars are
suddenly in one location
and lao is conveniently the only one who
knows where all of that cash is stashed
it's also worth noting that lao
refers to the 68 million dollars that
the joker stole in the opening scene of
the movie as relatively small
as you're all aware one of our deposits
was stolen
a relatively small amount 68 million and
no one has a big reaction to this number
being dropped which makes it seem like
it's mere chump change
lastly we get that shot of an 18-wheeler
truck that's loaded to the brim with
large bags of cash
if the first robbery of the movie netted
68 million dollars in hundred dollar
bills and it looked like this
an 18-wheeler full of bags stuffed with
hundred dollar bills would easily be
totaling
in the billions so the joker's a
billionaire throws it all away but
that's to be expected right
this is a guy who thrives on chaos he
famously describes himself as the man
with no plan
so none of this should really come as a
big surprise right do i really look like
a guy with a plan
you know what i am i'm a dog chasing
cars you know i just
do things except that couldn't be
further from the truth don't trust what
a person says about themselves
especially when the person is a
mysterious psychopath and a purple
jacket
throughout the dark night the joker
skulks around gotham and continually
tells people he meets about his origin
story and his love of chaos
but look at his actions and you see that
he is anything
but chaotic he storms into the mafia
meeting prepared with a pencil
and grenades he gets captured on purpose
and installs cell phones into his
henchmen's chests just to blow him up at
the perfect moment so he can escape with
lao
he arranges that opening heist with such
pinpoint
timing that a bus bursts through the
bank wall at precisely the time he
planned
over and over and over throughout this
movie we're presented with the classic
look at me i'm insane
but reading between the lines it's
immediately obvious that it's all an
act and the money pyramid is the best
example of this
because this scene isn't just about a
massive stack of cash
it's about a massive amount of time
precision
and organization arranging the money in
a pyramid like this is not
easy as we see the money is being kept
in loose sacks so it's up to the
henchmen to piece it all together and
time is against them after the joker
escapes from the police department the
sun is rising and we see batman brooding
over the still-burning remains of the
factory where rachel died he drops off
dense coin at the hospital later that
day then he goes back to his penthouse
and mourns the loss of rachel
the next day gordon visits dent in the
hospital and we cut to cars pulling up
to the boatyard with the sun directly
above them so we know
the goons had between 12 and 36 hours
max to build this thing assuming that
the joker has 16 henchmen working on it
all
laying down 60 straps of cash per minute
say
one per second which is already assuming
a lot to lay down over a hundred
thousand straps of cash for just the
first tier alone
you're looking at two hours of solid
work and that is the easy layer
from that point forward you're either
climbing on the work that you've already
done
or you're using heavy machinery like
forklifts and cherry pickers which is
just gonna slow down the entire process
the website movies films and flicks
estimates that it took
16 henchmen 27 hours in total to
construct that giant pyramid
around the clock day of work to build
this thing and for what he literally
builds an 11 foot tall
pyramid of cash so that one person can
see it burn
the whole scene is so precisely
practiced that the joker
only needs to say the word gasoline and
his henchmen know exactly what to do
none of this is chaotic i enjoy
dynamite gasoline
all of it is rehearsed it's all a
theater show a carefully crafted
set to make a point it's excessive but
more than anything else it goes against
everything that he says about himself in
the film
he is the most organized organized
criminal
of them all and that is why we've spent
so much time on a topic that literally
no one was asking about
to show you the true nature of the joker
but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and you know who's an even
bigger comic villain than the joker
kool-aid man oh yeah that's right step
aside
superman batman splash man and not man
it's all about the kool-aid man today
i'm doing a collaboration with myself
and my new channel food theory where one
of the episodes that i've uploaded today
covers how kool-aid man is connected to
the x-men and how he might be able to
find his way
into the marvel cinematic universe it's
one of five
more theory episodes that i'm launching
with today so if you want more theory
action
go over to food theory and check it out
and while you're there
be one of our first subscribers to the
newest channel now's your chance
hopefully when the channel gets big one
day you'll be able to go back and say
hey
i was there on day one watching those
videos and subscribing is literally
the single best thing that you could do
for the channel right now so if you do
find yourself with a little bit of extra
time today check out kool-aid man and
then
lick that red subscribe button that you
see on screen it makes all the
difference in the world to us working on
the channel and literally
zero difference to your youtube watch
page since we all know that youtube
don't actually show you the channels
that you subscribe to but the numbers
actually help us prove legitimacy of the
channel so that's why i'm asking for
your help
anyway let's make this thing a success
together shall we thank you for your
help i'm so excited to start this new
journey with you where we can just nerd
out even more together as a community
and
welcome to the food theory family i'll
see you all next week
across all three channels and until then
bon appetit